I'm Ryan O'Connell, the writer and creator
of the new Netflix series, Special.
And with me today
is the star of Special...
Ryan O'Connell!
Thank you for having me.
Am I backlit?
You're fine.
So, Special is based on
our shared life experiences.
Not to be a bitch,
but it's actually more my life experience,
because I'm the one who had to
live it out on screen, fearlessly.
But if you didn't have my words
you would have nothing to live out.
I hear you, but I also don't.
OK, well, what makes Special so...
special...
is that it takes someone who's been
kind of othered in our society,
and through brilliant,
thought-provoking writing,
it normalizes him.
I really think it was my acting
that helped normalize this.
When I first got the script for Special
it was under a pile of scripts
because I get so many offers.
And I got the script finally,
and I loved it, but I also wondered,
"Where does Ryan end
and the real Ryan begin?"
Yeah, that should've been really easy
because he's literally you, so...
That's not what my acting teacher said.
I slaved over these scripts,
these beautiful, gorgeous,
stunning, thought-provoking scripts
for two years.
Does writing not come naturally to you?
It's funny that you say that,
because actually it
poured out of me like a geyser.
Like, I literally needed, like,
a clean-up on, like, aisle four
because I was just gushing.
It's writing, it's a craft,
it's not like acting, no offense.
I think that the quality
really shows in the writing.
It's good because I'm good.
Just let everyone decide for themselves
when they see it, you know?
Writing... acting.
They'll decide, they know.